hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday December 2nd 2019 what's
going on how December 2nd everybody it's
official get your Christmas lights up
cuz it's the holiday season Dobie Dobie
doh you know it's funny they don't even
have to do those [ __ ] stories anymore
of like it is absolute pandemonium down
here at the mall there are no parking
spots people are screaming and they're
trying to grab the last micronauts yeah
but my cronuts huh they don't have to do
that anymore
right because everybody just orders from
Amazon
ok and if you think Santa's elves are
overworked I don't remember the last
time a Santa elf got crushed to death by
a forklift here's the thing everybody
why don't you think about all of these
people poor people who have to work like
double-time 14-hour shifts whatever the
[ __ ] it is they're doing over at that
goddamn hardware store you know go to
the mall huh just get in the SUV that
you didn't need go down to the [ __ ]
mall buy the [ __ ] you don't want give it
to the people you don't like so some of
these people over there at Amazon you
know could give their lower backs a
break for a second jesus what a [ __ ]
slave driver that guy must be alleged an
alleged slave driver I don't know I
don't remember last I have a slave got
benefits next question make sure she
accidentally chokes to death in the next
24 hours thinking anyway so that's the
deal I'm an [ __ ] I still drive around
and I go to toy stores that's my that's
my big [ __ ] move
it's actually you know it's finally paid
off after doing it for half a [ __ ]
century that's not true cuz I got my
driver's license at 16 I'm 51 for 35
years 35 years I've been driving down to
the [ __ ] malls you know December 2nd
and everybody just sits at home clicking
on this stupid bills drive it down to
the [ __ ] stores I just don't I don't
know
I can't this like the Internet it's
[ __ ] overwhelming to me so I just
stay I stay on like three different
sites
I go to YouTube I do the Twitter I do
the Instagram and I think that's my
world oh and I need to Google News when
I run out of [ __ ] to talk about here on
the podcast other than that I stay away
from it that's not true I go to StubHub
alright I go to the MotoGP and then I go
to the four major sports websites I do
that all right whatever it's still I can
breathe in a small town so yeah I got it
I gotta start my Christmas shopping but
I am up to my [ __ ] neck I turned the
corner on this [ __ ] exam I didn't
study my ass off trying to watch some
[ __ ] football I did watch Ohio State
vs Michigan started off great Michigan
scored first hail to the big there is
bad you know there's a lot of people out
there called for Jim Harbaugh his head
and I I don't know I don't know about
that I don't think that's right you're
talking about a guy he brought an NFL
team to a Super Bowl you're talking
about a guy he's saved no but what
Michigan fans he saved that [ __ ]
program there where that program was
okay he's still paying for that's what I
think I think that that Michigan
football program was so in the [ __ ]
toilet
it is affected Jim Harbaugh's ability to
recruit because if you looked at the
offensive line of Ohio State they
outweighed Michigan by like [ __ ] 50
pounds of guy that's why they were
running the ball down their [ __ ]
throats I mean what are you supposed to
do at that point
Rhodes
so I don't know okay so you gonna get
rid of him who are you gonna replace him
with there's a lot of emotion there's a
lot of emotion but I don't I don't
[ __ ] understand how Ohio State became
ranked number one when LSU beat number
one Alabama in Alabama to become number
one LSU didn't lose an Ohio State the
what they they [ __ ] they beat an
overrated Penn State team and then they
become number one [ __ ] ridiculous
I'm just glad Alabama lost again not
really I kind of miss rooting against
them but I don't know how many times are
they gonna throw a high o state into the
[ __ ] Final Four just to watch them get
[ __ ] shutout get their asses kicked I
don't understand what it is these people
have over the [ __ ] NCAA and these
[ __ ] Buckeye fans all they do is [ __ ]
moan and complain if they don't [ __ ]
get in there I don't know what's going
on every year they put the boring-ass
Buckeye let me see well the last time
they [ __ ] they won it once this this
decade right see Ohio State playoff
record well it's not not on a football
football and then whatever that one
[ __ ] year they they shouldn't even
even [ __ ] win the Big Ten and they
got in and then they got [ __ ] shutout
let's look at the powerhouses in their
division Rutgers Maryland Michigan State
Indiana and we get the [ __ ] out of here
they're the number one team in the
country I'm not saying they're not good
but it's just it's [ __ ] annoying as
an LSU fan to see your team not lose
knock off we actually knocked up another
one
I'll stake B well jim harbaugh ever beat
Ohio State my goodness is the the it's
it's it's going anyways alright the
Bruins OLS you won no one gives a [ __ ]
right they [ __ ] it then they beat who
they beat Texas A&M by like [ __ ] 90
points does that enough to make us go up
and over
I guess when Ohio State scores 70 points
on Maryland that that's enough to make
them the number one [ __ ] team in the
country combining that with a win over
mighty Penn State get the [ __ ] out of
here I can't wait to watch them lose in
the playoffs that's really gonna make me
happy it's [ __ ] you know they're like
the [ __ ] rich kids even though they're
a state school every [ __ ] year those
conser in it how the [ __ ] did they get
to be number one it's [ __ ] beyond me
maybe this is why they do it see [ __ ]
lose your [ __ ] it's making me hate Ohio
State that I don't hate Ohio State but
now I do
Bruins beat the hated Habs once again
beta once again after going down one
nothing on a wild deflection of first
period Oh goals for the next [ __ ] at 40
minutes and the Bruins explode in the
third period you see pasta narcs [ __ ]
goal absolute [ __ ] rocket nothing
Carey Price could do about it
top shelf making it one to one then it
was it back as scored next I actually
watched the game had a great [ __ ] time
I missed the Celtics but they played the
Knicks I know that they want you know
Marcus smart hurt his oblique and then
your New England Patriots what that bad
boo do but it'll put it over too little
too late against the Texans even that
last touchdown I mean they were just
going into a preventive help chew up the
[ __ ] clock but I don't know Tom Brady
doesn't have anybody to throw to
somebody on the New England Patriots
receiving court needs to step up and be
a definitive number two so Edelman can
get
and not be double covered every [ __ ]
second of the game you know they got to
start getting first downs because what's
happening is as great as our defenses
they spent too much time on the field
come third fourth quarter they're a
little tight there you go that's Mike
Brey that's my assessment before
everybody says Tom Brady's too [ __ ]
old he is too old to be playing tackle
football but somehow he's doing it but
the man simply does not have anybody to
throw to other than Edelman it seems the
other team knows that so they just
double up Edelman and then that's that's
been the [ __ ] problem we got some
protection issues we shall see it's late
in the season but I would never I would
never doubt Bill Belichick's ability to
turn a team around but it is getting
it's pretty late to have a game like
that from what I've seen during the
Belichick era so we'll see but as a
right now my picks for the Super Bowl ah
I like the Ravens and I like to see
Hawks I think an amazing matchup in the
playoffs would be Kansas City versus the
Ravens and I think defense wins that
game which you got to give the nod to
the Ravens I just think they got the D
they got the QB they got the coach they
got a running game they got a good
offensive line they're looking great and
they're [ __ ] tearing through the NFC
beaten everybody beat the 49ers
yesterday beat the Rams beat the [ __ ]
out of the Rams on Monday night
defending Super Bowl runner-ups it
counts for something I know they have in
a tough season and 49ers get their
second loss so I think that that puts
them Seattle has two losses Seattle won
Seattle won their head-to-head against
the 49ers so would they get home field I
don't know I have a kid I don't know
what's going on anymore let me look it
up real quick where the [ __ ] is that
there I click on that there we go all
right NFL standings sneaky pete carroll
i think he's the best coach in the NFC i
think they get through all right and FL
stand
yep up up doo-doo-doo-doo all right
Patriots 10 and to only one game ahead
of the Buffalo Bills though they led
we're gonna have to beat them again the
game will be in New England if I
remember correctly all right what about
the Dolphins I don't know it I got three
[ __ ] victories they'll like we know
I'll wait him what are you trying to
give us a number one pick in the draft
we don't want that to give that to the
[ __ ] Bengals at 1 and 11 1 and 11 all
right why won't you give me all the
[ __ ] teams why can't I get the
[ __ ] NFC you cuts all right NFC
standings NFC UFC world champion Jesus
Christ would you look what the [ __ ] oh
I'm gonna get me on that one what in the
[ __ ] I don't get this [ __ ] why does
it keep going to the [ __ ] AFC Oh cuz
you click on national I see why I type
in what I want and it still won't gives
it give it to me you don't realize how
[ __ ] pathetic is that the [ __ ]
Cowboys are 6 and 6 and they're in first
place do they still make the playoffs
alright oh that Seahawks play tonight so
the Seahawks win tonight according to my
public school math they are gonna be
tied with the 49ers having won their
head-to-head and one of these sons of
[ __ ] play again when did they play
against Seattle Seahawks 17 9 over the
Eagles Seattle Seahawks come on give me
your [ __ ] scout they just won't give
it to me they will not give it to me
Seahawks player Russell Wilson oh you
[ __ ]
Seahawks schedule do I got to look this
up Seahawks schedule when did they play
the 49ers again when doesn't Siri jump
in when he has to I swear to [ __ ]
Christ
oh the last game of the Wow who do they
got left they got the Vikings tonight
got the Rams and they got the Panthers
then they got the Cardinals I think that
they won the rest I think they win the
rest of that games right to the 49ers
and then we'll see then we'll see Rams
are at home
it's a divisional rivalry those Gabe's
are oh he's close who does who knows
what happens by the way you know when I
finally saw the movie I finally saw I
saw the Irishman
Matt and Scorsese the Irishman another
classic started a little slow and I got
worried and right around 40 minutes in
forget about it forgave my hit on that
Johnny Bosco ruined forget about it
because I always grew up saying that you
know all these hipsters thinking you're
quoting that movie it's like I'm not
quoting the movie the movie was quoting
people I grew up with anyway
Jesus Christ the performances in that
movie also too great stand-up comedians
in there Ray Romano and Sebastian
Maniscalco both crushed it I'm not going
to talk too much if I don't ruin any
part of the movie but I'm trying to
think the last time there was a movie
with that caliber of actor in it that
late in their careers I did get a little
sad in the end where I felt like they
were all saying goodbye Jesus Christ the
amount of screen time De Niro and Pacino
share is it's just I have to watch it
again it was so [ __ ] good absolutely
incredible movie I just can't rule I
don't ruin it Dom Dominic Lombardo Z and
it crushed it I got to know him this
year doing that Pete Davidson movie
please please please sit down and watch
that movie to give yourself two and a
half hours to just sit down and enjoy
it's absolutely incredible I had an
amazing weekend I saw that I also went
to go see Slayers last concert they're
retiring what a way to go out to
sold-out shows at the LA forum
I believe they were from Orange County I
remember growing up my couple my
relatives were really into Slayer and
all of that [ __ ] and I just couldn't
make the leap I was like the shit's just
too fast it's too [ __ ] crazy I
couldn't hear it and it wasn't until he
and they least always bugged me come on
man you got to get the second base drum
you got to play double bass and I was
stuck in my phil rudd John Bonham single
bass drum horseshit and then years later
the early 2000s I finally gave in and I
bought a [ __ ] double pedal and I
started trying to you know play some of
that Primus [ __ ] who by the way was also
on the bill it was it was phil anselmo
who i missed he played such a fast set I
try to you know when I got there I said
a lot of people I ran out there and I
missed the whole thing I heard it was
[ __ ] amazing then I saw ministry
didn't want to miss that Al Jourgensen
absolutely crushed it played my favorite
song of this stigmata so I was a happy
camper there and then I saw Primus go
out there [ __ ] destroy it give Slayer
their props and then Slayer Kevin came
out there the flames going the upside
down flame and cross they and they
opened with south to heaven ended with
Angel of Death and just just watching
the drummer just like I only
I honestly think after like the hardest
part of that drumming you know someone
was say to me goes he goes the feet are
hard enough but like the [ __ ] hands
just blowing around the toms the whole
[ __ ] set they just played 90 straight
minutes just snapped your head back and
it stayed there for 90 straight minutes
and then they said goodnight no encore
which I thought was the [ __ ] I did feel
a little bit sad you know I don't know I
always get a little bit melancholy
around the the holidays anyway you know
you start seeing people you know use you
only see for once a year they are old a
year older I watched the Irishman I felt
like they were saying goodbye
go to see Slayer he's saying goodbye and
he stood there looking at the crowd
that's really sad look on his face
before he waved goodbye and I was just
like oh my god you know I had a [ __ ]
brutal year this year as far as losing a
couple of friends I was just like I need
to go see like 21 pilots now I got to go
to a show with these young people with
their whole lives ahead of them
and you know whatever but uh I got it I
gotta hand it to the older fans there I
mean I would I never did this in my life
never went to a mosh pit in my [ __ ]
life I was like that is some stupid [ __ ]
right there but it is fun to watch and
there was a nice mosh pit going during
ministry and got going again of course
during Slayer but I actually got chills
in the end ones when they were saying
goodnight they were just standing there
letting the crowd cheer and the whole
crowd started sharing Thank You Slayer
Thank You Slayer was awesome and also
when we were in the parking lot it's the
Jim Breuer bit if he never saw Jim
Brewers bit on the Slayer fans climbing
over the chairs going so yeah they say a
climbing rope you were out in the
parking lot you just heard people don't
like like nobody has ever said Slayer it
has to be screamed with a certain level
of frightening urgency but anyways it
was a was a great time I saw nothing but
killer drummers all night I got to stand
to the side of the stage and and watch
all of them try to figure out what the
[ __ ] they were doing of course I
couldn't you know Tim Alexander I was
trying to watch like you know he had all
that the cool video going on behind him
so it was kind of making him in the dark
a lot so they had to wait to the screen
lit up so I could try to peek at his
bass drum work but uh they just [ __ ]
incredible men every band that night was
incredible so I hope you were there hope
you got a chance at least to see check
out that lineup on that tour cuz I
believe
that was the last night for all of them
not forever I think they all promise and
all then break off and do their own [ __ ]
after this all right with that let me
you know as funny as I went home the
next day right I was home the next day
and I tried to play south to heaven
which I used to be able to keep up with
you can't do it man it's like [ __ ]
taking time off from the gym all right
tipsy elves everybody all right it's
officially the holiday season whoa BtoB
boo and no party is complete without
getting your ultra festive holiday
clothing from tipsy elves tipsy elves is
one is a one-stop shop for all your
holiday clothing needs oh man I saw this
guy it's Larry at a Slayer Christmas
sweater run with 666 knitted in like
only an evil mother can do anyway they
sell one-of-a-kind Christmas sweaters
dresses family pajamas and onesies that
will transform your holiday party into
an unforgettable experience you will be
the life of the party
reveal your hilarious holiday alter-ego
in score bragging rights for having the
best Christmas sweater at the party talk
about your tipsy elves sweater and other
products you saw on the website well
alright I guess I got to go to the
website yeah that ad D I'm gonna I'm
really gonna look up tipsy elves and I'm
gonna get put on some sort of [ __ ]
watch list you never did anything creepy
then why are you trying to take why were
you looking up drunk elves oh wow yeah
these are definitely holidays you miss
you drink there's a bull's-eye and the
guys sweater get lit on top of a
Christmas tree well they're really
promoting getting [ __ ] up on this site
right to lit to quit what's this one say
Santa Claus is coming
okay I think I get the tone of this
website all right tipsy elves okay
they're a little you know a little drunk
they can't really you know say the word
know what's going on over there at that
sweater company all right
tipsy elves doesn't just sell Christmas
sweaters they also sell roofie pills I'm
kidding okay they are truly the one-stop
shop for all your festival holiday
clothing needs onesies cozy up cozy up
for movie night in their ultra comfy
flea you know I just realized the little
people have to wear onesies if they want
to wear pajamas
they like to do they make yeah they do
cuz they're like as tall as
eight-year-olds alright that was a dumb
question show how much you care about
them with festive marching matching
pudgy Jesus festive matching pajama sets
for the whole family perfect for that
family Christmas photo t-shirts larious
Christmas trees for both men and women
Christmas suits festive suits and ties
for guys looking to kill it at the
office party dresses slash leggings
adorable holiday dresses and crazy
comfortable leggings for all the jingle
ladies to show up in sleigh jingle
ladies white elephant gift cards tipsy
elephant has done the shopping for you
with their all-new carefully curated
white elephant gift section say snow
thank you too boring this year oh boy
try one of the hilarious awesome
hilariously awesome designs from tipsy
elves go to tipsy elves dot-com / Bertie
Ipsy elves lve lves calm / bird to get
20% off your entire order that's tipsy
elves calm / / for 20% off today okay
who's next oh policy genius hey dude
it's already December as much as we love
getting seasonal this month can be a bit
stressful too we've all got a long list
of things to do for the
if life insurance is one of the things
way down your list policy genius might
be able to help you cross it off no life
insurance yeah you got to get this stuff
right what if the tree shorts out you
get [ __ ] zapped sitting there in your
tipsy elf onesie they'll find the right
life insurance at the best price and do
all the work to get you covered updates
available I don't update anything sorry
that [ __ ] thing keeps popping up here
once you apply the policy genius team
weight policy genius makes finding the
right insurance in a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurance insurance to find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home and auto insurance or disability
insurance so if you need life insurance
but aren't sure where it is dad why not
start at policy genius.com
it only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply and
cross another thing off your to-do DLitt
to-do list policy genius when it comes
to life insurance it's nice to get it
right oh and look who's here lastly but
certainly not least least amps calm the
appetizers that started at all you know
what people hate more than anything
foreigners not foreigners being bothered
with little daily annoyances you know
what I'm talking about things like being
stuck in traffic awaiting the line or
just having to do things you don't want
to do well guess what you can get rid of
some of those annoyances just by using
stamps calm you know about stamps calm
they've been sponsoring this show for
over seven years now and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for the
holidays are coming up quickly get
started with stamps calm today so that
you so you're ready for the holiday rush
stamps.com brings all the services of
the post office right to your
you can buy in print US postage for any
letter any package right from your home
office home or office sorry you can even
pick you can even schedule a pickup with
the mail carrier so you you don't never
have to deal with LA traffic or at least
going to the post office you haven't
even gotten to the best oh I haven't
even gone to the best part yet with
stamps calm you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
priority mail why would anyone pay full
price when they don't have to
well maybe have unlimited funds and you
don't give a [ __ ] other than that III
agree with the question why would anyone
pay full price when they don't have to
stamps come is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 700
thousand small businesses already used
stamps calm right my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in birbee URR that stamps comm
enter ber stamps com never go to the
post office again you know what I was
watching that Kerry King bang in his
head while he was playing the original
guitarist when the original guitarist
and Slayer and that's what I root knew I
was old when I was watching him and I
was actually worried for his health I
was like I heard the lead singer had to
get spine surgery from like all the
years of like doing that helicopter move
you know that's why that guy Chris Slade
one of the many drummers for ac/dc he
never had to get spinal surgery because
he didn't have that hair to whip around
to do the helicopter move you know one
of the advantages of male pattern
baldness
I did think it was weird that the
guitarist Kerry King right he [ __ ] he
went bald he shaved the head so he
looked cool and then he got like male
pattern baldness tattoos like he
tattooed like the horseshoe back onto
his head I don't know it's like he
solved the problem and then he
highlighted it maybe that I don't know
like if I was starting a band that would
be a red flag it's like okay this guy
faces his problems head-on and then he
he's free of them before steering
directly back into it again
and now it's worse than ever sorry
anyway
alright I'm still not boozing can't you
tell can't you tell by the [ __ ] joy
in my voice oh my god
I have vibe it's just my life everything
food tastes better I got to do some
stand-up this week when I'm not [ __ ]
studying I got to get back out there
because I try to do a couple of stand-up
sets last week I tried and I succeeded I
did do some stand-up but it was
definitely a little bit of work there so
I'm actually going to be doing a I'm
putting together a benefit there's
there's a band that I'm a fan of and one
of the one of their members is going
through some I don't know some health
issues later on in life so he has a
charity so I'm gonna try to put together
a show and send the money for that thing
that's what that's what I'm trying to I
try to be a good guy do you don't mean
my wife will watch and Wheel of Fortune
the other night right that's one of the
things that we do we watch wheel of
fortune right you watch jeopardy feel
stupid and then afterwards you watch
wheel of fortune you feel really smart
except if you mean you have a slight
some sort of dyslexia or maybe you just
[ __ ] dumb is I can't solve any
puzzles and I actually find the more
letters that are up there the harder it
is for me so anyways as I thought it was
bubbling brook not babbling its bubbling
brook there's bubbles in the brook a
babbling brook would be if the the
[ __ ] water was talking to you right I
have to solve this bubbling or babbling
brook because it because the woman said
bubbling brook bubbles and babbling
brook a small tribute to does quit
waiting come on what do you got only
video here I want all
urban dictionary babbling brook I don't
want that knowing what kind of drugs
that means is that crackling you know
they heat it up and the [ __ ] starts
to bubble a Brooks water flows and
constantly traps air bubbling brook
bubbling babbling brook anyways the
[ __ ] answer was babbling brook the
lady said bubbling broken and pat sajak
was a little fine then the other person
had says babbling broken right so they
win the [ __ ] puzzle and you know
Wheel of Fortune has always been [ __ ]
notorious with not only their cheap ass
[ __ ] gifts in the end when they're
actually gonna owe your money they come
up with the most bizarre you know this
is a saying and it's just like you know
yeah alright CR whatever they got in UK
you got 30 seconds they can't [ __ ]
figure it out and then they go the
answer was crescent wrench toast some
[ __ ] bizarre whatever that's a bad
example but whenever we read it would
like what the [ __ ] is that
I'll tell you what the [ __ ] that is
Wheel of Fortune doesn't want have to
give away they 100 grand oh no oh look
who's down here just in time for the
Wheel of Fortune part bye-bye buddy
you're going to dance class hey Mia do
you want it yes
what are you gonna be there alright
alright ladies why not Jesus now you
guys have [ __ ] wheel of fortune blue
balls
alright I'm gonna I'll make sure I'll
get I'll get Nia on there for the for
the Thursday one it was [ __ ]
ridiculous though alright I'll tell you
if you know if you don't [ __ ] if you
don't say anything which I know your gun
oh what you know what you guys will cuz
whenever I [ __ ] make fun of [ __ ] you
guys always take the clips and then you
send it to the person like I really give
up
[ __ ] about him rather than I'm just by
myself trying to fill up a whole [ __ ]
hour huh
stir it up all these [ __ ] broads in
the internet that I don't even I don't
know they [ __ ] names I don't know the
[ __ ] these people are just making fun of
[ __ ] that's all nice yeah I got all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know you can generalize
a headliner but you can't generalize a
feature act Dennis oh my god how could
you [ __ ] do exactly what was done to
you anyway uh let's plow ahead here got
my shoulder going that's going you know
[ __ ] this let's just get to the goddamn
stool let's get La - try to [ __ ]
stretch it anymore I was gonna I was
gonna tell the wheel of fortune story
and she just [ __ ] that old thing over
didn't she yeah she did you know what is
great about my daughter though she
[ __ ] loves uh she's kind of a car guy
like she likes riding in my truck and
you know and him in my in my daily
driver
she's always I want ride Dada's car and
you sit over here and I see here okay
that's a big thing okay and of course
she has me sitting in the passenger seat
and she thinks because now that she
knows how to ride a tricycle
that she knows how to drive a car that's
her big thing you know that and trying
to delay going to bed I want brush teeth
sweetheart you already brushed your
teeth
I need brush teeth again it's it hurts
it's stuck
pointing at her teeth or something then
when you finally get her in a crib she's
like okay tomorrow we're gonna watch
puppy dog pal and have smoothie okay
die die okay okay okay buddy I'm just
planning it all out you might have to
check with your mother all right
international holiday overeating all
right here we go hi you pie bacon ginger
you know I try to
a pumpkin pie I got a great recipe for
that although it said leave it in there
3540 minutes I would have gone 45
minutes I kind of just stick it back in
that's what she said that's what he said
right so I'm supposed to say never hi
you pie baking ginger I've been
listening to your podcast for years and
finally caught my first live show in
Berlin last January first time running
to you two okay
we may not celebrate Thanksgiving in
Greece but we do try to kill ourselves
by eating a lot every Easter Sunday well
there we go
although I would love to hear Yanis
Papas tell me how Greek Easter
Thanksgiving has nothing on Greek Easter
that's why I love following him he's
always talking about how everything that
Greeks do I guess their Easter Sunday
but and no matter how good they're used
to Sunday is to have to go to that
14-hour Mass that they have like one of
my best friends growing up was 100%
Greek and he would just sit there like
they had like a room you had you go out
and you take a break from as they go on
and on I think they killed Jesus again
in like real time during Greek East or
something like that anyways
although the Christmas period always
involves a lot of eating to Easter
Sunday presents a tougher challenge
since we have to sit through two heavy
meals in a period of less than 15 hours
the challenge is even harder for those
who may have been fasting before that
for as long as 40 days during Lent the
first meal is to be head after Minda
that's actually really dangerous to come
off a fast and then chow down like that
isn't it typically right after returning
from church and involves alright the
first meal is to be had after midnight
typically right after returning from
church and involves he put a capital
letter in here to help me out mega-rich
stuff is that I mega rista a soup made
mainly of lamb and trails oh boy can't
believe I'm missing out on that Greek
chitlins
but since that's a bit of an acquired
taste there is some there is usually
some other type of meats to salads and
dressing salads and eggs dessert is
optional
now when cooking guts entrails I know
they boil them but isn't the [ __ ] still
in the water do you then take the guts
out and then hose it off anyway the
second heavier and usually much longer
in duration meal starts around midday it
may go on for several hours the
centerpiece is the over leas the O ve L
capital L IAS he's trying to help me out
although Lea's lamb or young go roasted
on a spit but there is a ton of other
meat salads and desserts
since family and friends who visit all
brings some of their own the feast can
go on for hours and there's always
leftovers for Easter Monday when the
whole thing is repeated thankfully at a
smaller scale greetings from Greece and
go [ __ ] yourself I gotta get I got to do
a kick over there I'm not going that
weekend though Jesus Christ I'm sorry I
got to look up how to cook how to cook
and trails bring a large pan of water to
a boil and add the diced meat and radish
wait wait wait how to properly cook
chitlins let's try this oh my god this
just makes me [ __ ] gag chitlins or
pork intestines are a favorite among
southern families no they were oppressed
and they got the worst part of the pig
that's what it is traditionally there
are prepared during the holiday but deep
freezing makes them available year-round
oh boy be sure to wash any surface
in your hands thoroughly with a bleach
solution to avoid contamination while
handling raw chitlins chitlins are very
good in our allowed in moderation under
some popular low carb diets be certain
to pass the vinegar and hot sauce enjoy
okay soak the chitlins and cold water
throughout the cleaning stage each
chitlins should be examined and run
under cold water all foreign materials
gross should be removed and discarded
chitlins should retain some fat so be
careful to leave some on after each [ __ ]
no thank you
okay thank you thank you very much oh
boy
you know what's hilarious you notice one
like white people appropriate black
culture they kind of leave chitlins
behind Jesus Christ all right girlfriend
considering spending Christmas with our
ex oh there's an easy well I don't have
to read this one
that's a [ __ ] big see you later
sweetheart you go do that and be sure
you slip and fall onto his [ __ ] when
you've had too much spiked eggnog
alright alright yo bill burr it's
freezing out here
I've been dating this girl with a kid
for a while now he's five years old we
get along great
I love this girl I love this kid and
they both love me the kids father is a
douche as a douche bag and they
currently trade the kid off to each
other every week months ago my
girlfriend was ecstatic about spending
every holiday together but recently when
I asked how we were doing Christmas she
said she didn't know then this morning
she casually threw out the idea of
sleeping at her ex's house Christmas Eve
so her him and the kid can have one
Christmas and not have the kid have to
do too
I am not at all comfortable with this
and was speechless when she mentioned it
me and my girlfriend don't have a place
yet we both live at our dad's house late
20s BRR
I want us all to do Christmas at my
dad's place but she said the feelings
wouldn't be right for her kid now she's
saying her kid I don't get it bill we
have plans to be together forever both
of us agree on that I don't want her to
shack up with every with her ex every
holiday just because it will confuse the
kid when plenty of parents are split up
and it's perfectly normal for them to
have two Christmases I don't want this
to become a thing Christmas is all about
traditions and I want us to build one
together how do i express this to her
without seeming like I'm worried about
it well you are worried about it I
wanted to know I trust her but at the
same time it's weird right her sharing a
magical Christmas morning with her ex
and not the man she's with now it
[ __ ] hurts well there you go I would
take the [ __ ] out of there just tell
her that it you just need her to explain
this to you then you need her to listen
to you and hear how it's making you feel
and then you guys have to talk it out
and you got to figure it out that's what
I would say that that's that's basically
what I would do I didn't understand all
the [ __ ] that was involved in there you
got the kid there
no but the guy's a douchebag is he gonna
at least try to bang his ex while she's
there I would think if you have a kid
there's a lot of guilt when you go
through a divorce it might be something
like that it could be anywhere from
she's slowly getting back to this with
this douche - she feels guilty I don't
know but you need to sit down and talk
it out with her that's what I would do
and just say what you're feeling without
getting mad and without saying [ __ ] okay
which is really hard for a guy because
you're not allowed to cry so your woman
could just sit down how do you think
then you'd feel [ __ ] horrible than
that would be it you know but you can't
be like you know then why are you being
so mean you become the mean person so
it's a very delicate delicate thing it's
like the end of a Tom Cruise or a Will
Smith movie you know where they got a
dude do they cut the red wire do I cut
the blue wire I don't know what to do
here right I'll walk away slowly from
the explosion you know it's that type of
[ __ ] but I gotta be honest with you I
think she anticipated that you would not
be comfortable with it by the way she
did it just kind of casually went from
like yeah we're gonna [ __ ] hang
together to like you know I don't know
yeah you know think I'm just gonna kind
of [ __ ] hang onto that
yeah you guys need to have a talk about
that one because what does that mean is
this starting this tradition then you
know they're gonna put together like
just sit down and just say listen they
were let that relationship failed okay
it's a failure why would you go back to
a failure you know you can't do that
just sit down and tell her what you
think you without saying [ __ ] are
getting mad and just tell her in the end
all right just let you know this is this
is really hurting and hurting my
feelings because that's what I'm feeling
and you do what you're feeling and say
what you're feeling and I'm trying to be
more evolved as a male and tell you what
I'm feeling not saying you can't go you
just ripping my heart out Merry
Christmas
should I buy my crush a Christmas
present no creepy they don't know that
you're in [ __ ] crushing on them all
right hey old Billy freckles big fatty
is showing a long time listener I have a
little dilemma with the lady
I have a crush on a girl that I have
known for three years now she is a
wonderful person but we work together I
was thinking of giving her a Christmas
present to show her that I'm into her
after hashtag me too I'm a little scared
as you should be
and I don't know what to get well don't
get her worried what that [ __ ]
lunatic at the Morning Show would get
those chicks they watch you at dildo
Merry Christmas I was hoping you and the
lovely Mia could give me some advice /
suggestions if it's a good idea and if
so what would be a good dev gift thank
you and go [ __ ] yourself
oh look it okay come on that's me
all right um let's see what would I do
uh that's very different does she know
that on any level that you like her um
you've been crushing on her for a while
now I I think you just you got it you
got to move your conversation past just
being friends at work you got to start I
don't know man I don't know how this
works in today's age I mean you day and
age I think you got to start hitting on
her you know I mean I know that there's
a lot of hairy leg women out there that
resent that you know maybe if they
shaved their legs that would happen more
often and they wouldn't be so upset
about it oh my god it's like so annoying
when like a guy likes you so [ __ ]
about shut up good that [ __ ] [ __ ]
moaning and complaining I want you to
initiate it but not initiate initiated I
want you to be confident and strong but
you want everything right that's disable
your stick is that what you [ __ ] say
it you want the whole thing to go
exactly how you want it to go is
basically what you say this is our nuts
webinar they routinely write articles
can women have it all that's how [ __ ]
nuts and selfish they are no you can't
have it all there's always a sacrifice
that's made okay how many [ __ ] times
do you dumb broads got to ask that
[ __ ] question no you can I become a
mom and it won't hurt my career no if
you want to have a kid and you don't
want to hurt your career it's gonna hurt
you as a parent you have to make [ __ ]
sacrifices and so does the guy [ __ ]
dopes Jane we really have it all I don't
know but God knows you're gonna try
should I buy my crush a Christmas
present I would not I wouldn't I you
know I
would somehow get it I mean I don't know
it's been three [ __ ] years at some
point I mean you got to [ __ ] tell her
how you feel and then ask her out yeah
because what you're gonna do is she
asked around she says yes and then you
guys are dating this time next year the
level of Christmas present that you're
gonna have to buy cuz you already bought
her a certain level present when you
guys weren't even in a relationship you
know when she's going to be reading all
these articles can we really have it all
can I have four kids and also work 80
hours a week and everybody's happy now I
want to [ __ ] dumb question
yeah that's what I would do I I think
rather than buy her a gift I think you
need to verbally communicate on some
level that you're interested in taking
her out on a date all right rather than
coming out of nowhere with no sup no
conversations to that effect then just
show up with like a clattering I think
that would be a little weird alright
time for advice it oh my god time for
advice this person just did the layup
I'm sorry I'm gonna have to [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to play it again
you know wait sorry
was a lamp was a
was I supposed to do all right
hello Billy the sober dad I loved I love
that title I don't enjoy it at night but
I do love it all right I'm a big fan of
yours from Portugal and I need your
advice all right
I started Oh Lisbon eight from Lisbon I
started college two years ago and I'm
not doing great well guess what I can
relate I used to be in the top of my
class and now I flunked a bunch of
subjects all right now that I never did
that I sucked in high school and
continued the tradition in college I'm
in college from mechanical engineering
thanks to my love for physics and math I
started writing a book and it's been
hard to do both things and stay
motivated for college I'm also trying to
convince my parents to buy me a drum kit
since I can't afford it out of my own
pocket well you got better get your
grades better before that or get the
drum kit before your grades come out I
want to learn the drums right my book
and finish college how do I find
motivation in time for everything
oh look at this guy he wants it all
thanks for the podcast you've cheered me
cheered up my Mondays and Thursdays your
dear fan I can't say the name PS it's
okay if you can't pronounce my name most
Americans fail at that Wow oliveria
Oliveira it sounds like the wrestler
that loses every week Jose Estrada okay
all right sir well thank you so much for
the kind words it's cool that you want
to learn drums it's cool that you want
to write a book but your priority right
now is finish in college and if you're
not gonna drop out you're just gonna
prolong this thing which is gonna get in
the way of you eventually finishing your
book and your drums your parents are
probably helping you out with college
you just have to prioritize things
all right the priority every day is you
get your schoolwork done first okay and
then you figure out what's your priority
writing this book or drums okay then
maybe write in the book is second in
line and then the drums is how you blow
off steam
that is how I would do it all right I
wouldn't try to convince my parents to
buy me a drum kit either if I wasn't
doing well in school
so I think you got that creative thing
where you got a little bit of a DD and
you just need to you know if you just
let it ping-pong in your head it's
you're still gonna be confused to saw
works to me I have to like make a list
every day and just prioritize the things
that need to be done and I just knock
them out and having a DD is a great
[ __ ] thing it gives you [ __ ]
energy just has you you can do a lot of
[ __ ] all right
and a couple of adjustments like a list
because then you can get all a DD or
[ __ ] OCD about the [ __ ] list and I
like check and [ __ ] off because it makes
me feel like I'm getting stuff done so I
would just prioritize for your
schoolwork get that done first get your
grades up then I would write you a book
and then I play your drums that's how I
would do it personally and not to
mention you can also you can also buy
you could find a cheap one you know then
your parents can't hold it over your
head you know that's just that's my own
advice but it seems to me like you're
gonna die but I think you're gonna do
really well in life because you're not
doing well in school and you're writing
a book and you're also interested in
music it seems like you're gonna have a
very passionate like you're gonna follow
your passions in life which is great and
the fact that you can actually handle
you you love physics and math but you
can also write a book and you're into
drums you're very well-rounded person
you just got to dial up the studying a
little bit I think you should be fine
all right buddy good luck to you and I
hope you get that drum kit all right
overrated underrated underrated being
prepared always having napkins and
toilet plate paper / clothes in your car
that's sorry butchered the punchline
they're underrated being prepared always
having napkins and toilet paper /
clothes
your car Wow all right I didn't want to
know what that's about
overrated stockpiling guns and [ __ ] you
can only use one right I don't know
that's exactly what I thought you got
all of those [ __ ] guns you can only
shoot two at a time and you know how
accurate is that and then half of those
guns if you emptied the clip you'd be
deaf for the rest of your life but the
zombies would be dead I don't know I
have a weird thing with guns
I absolutely [ __ ] like I like guns
the way I like cars I like the older
ones I like like a Glock to me
it's just like you know when they
started rounding off every four-door
sedan
[Music]
let me see here classic guns classic
firearms Jesus Christ first tipsy elves
now classic firearms like somebody's got
to be concerned here all right I don't
like the German Luger I'm not into that
thing just makes me think of evil [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I like a [ __ ] revolver
old-school revolver a 38 snubnose I like
all that [ __ ] ease to seeing all the
[ __ ] cop shows whenever they had an
evil person they always had the so they
always had a one of those Lugar's Wow
look at those [ __ ] World War two
rifles or reissues of them I thought I'd
get some [ __ ] images here come on man
well the [ __ ] out okay let's go let's go
images images here come on you [ __ ] he
has the worst internet ever three
classic guns that ought to be I don't
like those three musketeer ones I'm not
so oh yeah look at that Dirty Harry
[ __ ] 44 Magnum before they were like
silver when they were like black with
the wooden handle those are [ __ ] cool
yeah I like a six
the old revolve a six-shooter revolver
and that thing is just [ __ ] bad this
might be the American coming out of me
but that's [ __ ] beautiful a gun
inspired by classic western TV shows of
the 1950's that were dominating the
family room of nearly every home in
America the Ruger is single six has gone
on to become stuff of legend yeah I mean
that's just a [ __ ] gorgeous gun look
at that
[ __ ] beautiful yeah am I gonna buy
this thing
can I just buy this is this America can
I just [ __ ] click on here what's your
background work in the ice house maybe
sometime this month all right you seem
pretty good to make but we're only
giving you five bullets for this six
shooter just so we know you know see
what you do you know you know you don't
shoot anybody the first month will give
you will give you that last bullet yeah
I like that and I like those old
Winchester rifles let me see here a
Winchester rifle oh yeah I mean that's
that's just the one right there that
every [ __ ] badass in every cowboy
movie I ever saw let me see how much is
150 150th anniversary Jesus Christ mm
$19 add to the cart I could just buy
this I can just buy this wait a minute
this is [ __ ] insane I mean I feel
like as an American you have to have one
of those hanging over your fireplace
right I said get out
150th anniversary model eight 1873
polished blue lever lever action rifle
44-42 in Chester's head of 44 over 40
[ __ ] over and under whatever the [ __ ]
you guys say that's a [ __ ] beautiful
gun
all right let me look up the only last
one my Mount Rushmore of guns okay 38
snub nose all right you know what I just
realized I don't like that I just like
the name come on come on 38 caliber
pistol let's see what this thing looks
like I shot a five shot 38 one time oh
that was it every detective had that
[ __ ] gun
I like it with the longer barrel yeah I
like a revolver man that [ __ ]
cool-looking well there you go
well that's a 357 Magnum yeah I think
anything that like Charles Bronson or
Clint Eastwood had when I was growing up
I like whoa that is a [ __ ] can the
real top five the real top guns five
best 357 and 38 caliber guns on the
planet you know it's funny says people
argue over this the way people argue top
guitarists all all you know of all time
there's no [ __ ] way the snub-nosed
1978 nickel-plated [ __ ] is the best
[ __ ] gun out there all right so there
you go I I actually I'm a big fan of
guns I'm scared shitless of them look
because I didn't grow up around so I'm
not comfortable with them but uh I think
Glocks and all the new [ __ ] is all
boring as hell but the old-school wants
the old-school [ __ ] rifles and the
the old-school [ __ ] revolvers those
[ __ ] can it's I think those are the
[ __ ] all right that is the podcast
everybody this Thursday you will hear
the end of the Wheel of Fortune story
where I was really offended by what my
wife said to me and it's been a long
time since I made her laugh that hard
because it was one of those things was
she realized that what she said was
[ __ ] up but it was just something
silly so we'll bring it we'll bring her
bring her on on Thursday it's gotta be a
dumb podcast all right tonight what do
you got the Seattle Seahawks versus what
the Rams is
was playing tonight I have no idea
sneaky Pete's gonna get into the [ __ ]
Super Bowl that is my call that is my
call and he's gonna be playing the
Ravens as Lamar Jackson [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] help would beat the goddamn
49ers once again once again tearing
through the NFC all right that's it
that's my prediction go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday